Speaker 1: The primary funding source of The
David Pakman Show is your support through our
membership program. I invite you to sign up at
Join Packman Qcom grab yourselves a membership.
We do an extra show every single day for our
paid members. It's called the Bonus Show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, thank you, Alex. Many people
enjoy the bonus show daily, and so I would not
listen to Alex Jones on that. You can sign up at
join Packman dot com and use the coupon code. Big
voting 22. Big voting 22 to get yourself a healthy
discount off of the cost of a membership. There
is a video going viral of pro-choice activists
crushing, yes, the Democratic Party over immediate
opportunistic fundraising attempts, saying, oh,
the Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade. Rush
us money. Give us money so that we can fix this.
And we're going to look at that video now. I am
thrilled that this is getting attention. In fact,
I tweeted about the vile nature of both sides.
Immediately fundraising off of the Supreme Court
decision. Last week, I tweeted, quote, Is there
anyone not raising money off of today's Supreme
Court decision? Fundraising emails off the
charts, right wingers saying now is the time to
keep going, give us money. Left wingers saying,
give us money to fix this. And I didn't find
either of those particularly good faith, rather
finding it completely opportunistic. So let's
check out this video which has gone completely
viral. This is Zoe Warren and Julianne,
dear, editor of Rise Up for Abortion. They
spoke to MSNBC and they beautifully point out
the absurdity now of Democrats and yes,
Republicans as well. The Republicans as well,
don't get me wrong, of Democrats immediately
saying give us cash so that we can fix this when
we know why this happened. And part of it has to
do with Democrats. And, of course, much of it has
to do with the fact that I mean, when you start
the sequence of events, it's Donald Trump won in
2016 and then appointed Supreme Court justices.
And then it was the exact playbook. Republicans
started challenging abortion at the state level
with the goal of appealing it to the Supreme
Court, with the goal of getting the Supreme Court
to overturn Roe v Wade. We predicted it in 2016,
and that's exactly what happened. Let's check
out this video. Absolutely fascinating and well.
Speaker 3: So I received a text message from Joe
Biden's campaign yesterday saying that the Supreme
Court had overturn Roe versus Wade and that it
was my responsibility to then rush $15 to the
Democratic National Party. And I thought that was
absolutely outrageous, because my rights should
not be a fundraising, fundraising point for them
or a campaigning point. They have had multiple
opportunities to codify ROE into law over the past
20, 30, 40, 50 years, and they haven't done it.
And if they're going to keep campaigning on this
point, they should actually do something about
it. Yeah, I was worried about school court and
most worried about what comes next because Roe
versus Wade was a precedent for Obergefell versus
Hodges loving versus Virginia Irving versus Texas
gay marriage, interracial marriage and privacy
in the bedroom. Correct. And those as Clarence
Thomas came out yesterday, they're going to
be falling like dominoes. You come from Texas,
you're in Austin, Texas. There's a trigger law in
place in Austin. In 30 days, abortion is going to
be banned in your state. Abortion has been banned
at six weeks in my state since last September,
which is an essential all out ban because most
women don't even realize they're pregnant before
that point. And there are there are women in Texas
who've already died and have already been arrested
for having an abortion or a miscarriage, because
we can't really tell that. It seems like you
have obvious anger towards the Democratic Party
because you feel as if they've missed chances
to codify Roe up until this point. And then here
we are. What does that mean for you when it comes
to midterm elections and getting more Democrats
elected to move forward with trying to codify Roe?
Well, when it comes down to the primaries, which I
think are coming up in the next couple of months,
it means that we need to get as many people
to the polls as possible to vote for more
progressive Democrats. We need to get the old
white Democrats out of office and put in new,
younger people who will actually defend the
rights of women and people all over this country.
And then when it comes to midterms, we
need to make sure that we have those same
people who voted for the progressive people in the
primaries coming back to the midterms and voting
again and making sure that these more progressive
Democrats get into office. And kind of.
Speaker 1: So she's absolutely right. I don't
tend to do the identity politics stuff in terms
of saying we need to get white Democrats out. I
want a diversity of representation that that's me.
Okay. So don't ascribe saying get white people
out to me. That's not the way I would. I would use
that term. But this is completely spot on in the
sense that both parties have used abortion rights
as a divisive fundraising issue for decades.
I happen to agree with the political position
of the Democrats. As an individual because
I'm pro-choice. But this has been an issue
that's been a fundraising issue on both sides for
decades. In some sense, I recognized and I knew
that Democrats I'm sorry that Republicans benefit
from Roe v Wade in the sense that it's something
they can keep fundraising on as long as Roe v Wade
is there. Republicans can say, give us money to
oppose Roe v Wade. Now they've gotten Roe v Wade
overturned. So some have been emailing and saying,
well, now, now, how are Republicans going to raise
money? Well, they're going to be fine. Now they're
going to say let's push for a federal ban on
abortion. That would be the next step. Now they've
eliminated Roe v Wade, which kind of enshrines
abortion as as a right. But the next step would
be, well, let's let's get a ban on it. And at
the state level, they can work on bans. They can
start working on blue states. Right. Even if it's
unlikely to succeed, they can say, give us money
so we can get abortion banned in California and in
Connecticut and in New York, in Massachusetts, in
Maryland or wherever else. So they're still going
to have ways to fundraise. And the crazy thing is,
the Republican continued fundraising on this issue
is going to be more credible feeling in a sense,
because when you look at the Democratic Party,
the protesters here are correct. There have been
so many missed opportunities to codify Roe
v Wade and abortion rights and to do so many
other things. So while you can pick the side
that matches your political position and say,
well, I'll give the money, the Republicans now
have actually accomplished something major. They
have gotten Roe v Wade overturned. And so their
fundraising on this issue is almost more credible
than that which we're seeing by Democrats.
And I got those fundraising e-mails as well.
There was something pathetic about it.
There was something disgusting about it
saying if they overturn Roe v Wade, send us $15
now. $15 to do what exactly? Particularly when
we need people in the Democratic Party in elected
power who are going to fight much harder for it.
So very interesting. Very interesting viral, viral
interview there and we'll continue covering that.